how are you feeling today
i'm okay i've had a bit of time to
decompress and think about things but
still so
so wild
seriously wild even watching that happen
it was like
what is happening right now like i can't
even imagine how you were feeling in
that moment so
how did you feel when you heard the
votes were nine to two
at first i heard the votes were nine to
two and i'm like oh my gosh i thought
because at first i thought it was gonna
be a six
as a six like five or really really
close and then i heard 92 and i'm like
oh i got i got a couple more votes and
then they're like 70 you're evicted i'm
like what i had no idea complete
complete blind side complete blind side
who do you think was behind all of this
because obviously people were plotting
and planning for it to be such a switch
yes um
i definitely think summer
summer is very strategic and she's a
great player and i think she had a big
part in that because her and josh are
very close so i definitely think she had
a big part in that and i'd give her
kudos because she pulled off a big move
if it was her
and no hugs when you left why not i did
not want to touch a single person
none of them get me out
fake
no no didn't want to touch a single
person no hugs no hugs no love no hugs
you said you were golden in last night's
episode you said you were golden you
were you were safe what made you feel so
safe this is big brother right so
anything could happen
anything could happen and i had several
conversations with people where i was
the one saying you can never feel
comfortable in this game and all you
have is your safety and until you win
that you never know what could happen i
felt comfortable because of the bonds
that i had built with people and i had i
had campaigned to them they had told me
yeah i'm voting for you to stay i take
things at face value i'm a very upfront
person and i told the house guest that
so maybe they took that at face value
and used that against me which is
totally fine kudos to them and also kyle
was advocating for me as well i had
people saying kyle's doing a really good
job to push for you to stay but i never
gave up even before the vote i kept
asking people like do i still have your
vote is this good
but they they did the damn thing so they
got me out
earlier in the week you and moose and
kyle had a conversation in the hoh room
it was a little heated
how did you feel leaving that
conversation could you still trust kyle
or
moose in that conversation afterwards i
i was so conflicted i went back and
forth with
who moose is an amazing talker and kyle
i don't even know what was going through
his head during that moment or any
moment at all so i didn't really know
where i stood with either of them or who
to trust
i just knew i could only trust myself
what are your thoughts on kyle's uh
messy hoh
oh my god being like a casualty in the
middle of it for no reason um i think it
was an absolute disaster it was very
emotionally driven
mind you being in that house and
watching it from your tv at home are two
different things i totally get it i
don't know what i would have done in his
position i definitely would have not put
up my own alliance member
but
very messy very emotionally driven i
think it'll be the detriment to his game
so what was your game play what were you
thinking that you would have done if you
had won hoh next or if you were still in
the house
if i was still in the house i definitely
would have put kyle up it would have
just been easy to do i'm sure he would
have understood and i definitely would
have put summer up as well because i
think she's the strongest player in that
house she's very
strategic she's very social and that is
amazing as someone who respects this
game to watch and see but that's a
player you need out of that house if
you're trying to win
who do you think is running the house
right now
i want to keep on the consistency of a
tanisha summer i definitely think
they're killing they're killing the game
in that house
how did you feel about all the alliances
blowing up this week
i to be honest wasn't even aware of many
alliances whatsoever i knew kyle had
some stuff going on and i definitely
knew there was something happening with
the other side of the house but it
wasn't crystal clear to me because
everyone was so intertwined and everyone
was just running their mouths a little
bit and then
retracting back so i was like where
where are these what is everybody doing
you just never you never know you really
never know in the house
do you wish you did anything differently
you know i went in wanting to play true
to who i am just silly lighthearted fun
social i think i did a great job at that
i wanted to be myself
it's so hard going into it wanting to be
a different person from who you are
because you're already taking so much
out of your comfort zone
yeah no
what was the hardest part for you living
in the house
i think the hardest part about living in
the house was just getting adjusted to
all of the personalities there was about
eight virgos in the house
and virgos are very
specific in the way they like to live
and all of us were so different so it
made it just so wild and just so wild to
be around all the different
personalities
who was on your radar who were you very
suspicious of obviously summer but was
there anyone else
no one else specifically marty a little
bit marty marty definitely raised some
red flags especially after that
conversation and hearing that he went
around to the whole entire house saying
ah after a conversation i still wasn't
sure i may have put her up you know it's
like okay you say you're a man of your
word but you're gonna go against your
word so that definitely raised some red
flags to me
um
yeah not no one really else was on my
radar
who do you think could win it all
oh gosh
i definitely i'm gonna stick with summer
i definitely think she could win it all
um
were there any bb canned house guests
that you looked up to before going in
the house that you kind of wanted to
mold your gameplay after
no one specific that i wanted to mold my
gameplay after but i definitely loved
watching kayla i loved watching
cassandra i loved watching sabrina they
were all very very loud very out there
players and it was just so fun to watch
and
yeah
are you going to continue watching this
season
i am definitely going to continue
watching this season because i want to
see all the chaos ensue in that house
and just erupt i want to see everything
happen
and my last question for you is do you
have a message that you want to leave
your fans with because people love you
they love what you're doing especially
after the explosion in the hoh room you
gain some fans
oh goodness um
i
went in being true to myself i wanted to
stay true to who i was i think i did a
good job at that
um
what is it the best game necessarily no
but going into that house you never know
what you're gonna get
and
never underestimate yourself because
what you can do is beyond what you think
you can do